hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now it's
still late
well not to you but to me it's still
late 9:45 and I'm very tired but I'm
gonna keep playing subnautica but I will
let you guys know that there was a sorry
there was a rather significant update or
at least that's what the developers said
and this game is now out of date
compared to what I was playing before so
there was a lot of new features added
and I did have this system where you
could grieve you save but apparently
that's not good enough and there's a lot
of things that'll be missing so in the
next episode if you guys would like a
next episode let me know I will be
starting a new game starting over from
fresh and then I won't be screaming so
much like a little babu is this is a
cloud of those scissor fish tiny and
elusive so someone said that I should
look in the back of my thingamabob er
and there would be a way to have ox to
joe knees all over the place but in case
that doesn't work i've got big old white
pieces of pipe that I'm gonna lay down
from the surface of the ocean down to my
little habitat over there and then I'm
gonna be able to pipe down all that
delicious delectable air into my lungs
directly down into my new habitat is
that going down or coming up please tell
me it's coming up because I do not like
the darkness okay she's coming up okay
alright so supposedly I don't know how
this works but supposedly this should be
able to help me pump down air anyway am
i whoa I didn't want these nerf bat
oh god that's not know that oh my god
that's what have I done what am i Ross
what what fresh hell is this I'm making
DNA molecules I've ran completely out of
pipe something has gone horrible
and I don't know how to set him straight
there was probably a tutorial don't know
oh god that is bad I am just the worst
okay boy oh look it's yeah
connects existing blue pipe by aiming at
it so when I came at it there seems to
be some sort of a band so my assumption
is that I need to get the band so that
it does not be stupid
Stoops shirt for stupid I make it short
for all the people that can't understand
the full word of stupid nevermind
okay so someone said that there was this
is be going off you guys so you guys
could lead me astray but somebody said
that there was some kind of aramid
[ __ ] on this base in the thingamabob
er which would be great because I hate
going up to the ocean front to breathe
every few seconds technology there's
gotta be a way I know what new is so
Observatory that would be cool Oh Oh
still going down I thought I was paused
what kind of idiot am i it's been a
while I got that cincinnati blood in me
I ain't too smart no more drank the
Cincinnati water not as good as this la
water which I'm pretty sure is still
just as bad that's besides boy
why are you floating above the ocean get
out of here with your craziness it's not
being so weird so what I need is more
materials in general and then I need to
decide how I'm gonna expand my base
because in the last episode my only
objective was to actually try to build
my base
wow that's a weird am I even human that
did not look like a human thing and I
won't complain too much so what was I
saying yeah I was so concerned with
building the base that I actually did
not know what there was silver I've been
hunting around the entire ocean floor
scavenging everything I possibly could
I went far and wide and almost died a
million times for gosh - god I got so
much pipe scrub pipe seamoth fragment I
guess it's important Salvage give me
more if you'll give me fire give me
Salvage in my face I don't know that's
all I can do inventory full I'm a space
to salvage take I guess a lot at least
it's plenty of it
I mean I don't know if this is the most
efficient way of getting titanium why do
you people keep jumping in and out of
the water like that stop being weird
you are pure and simple land what are
you ok do you need help
probably part of the upgrade process to
my save and it didn't go too well at
least as far as my understanding it goes
ok I'm gonna come back when I have
something to actually report so BRB in
case anyone was curious I've been rock
climbing I may I mentioned that in the
last episode I can't remember but all my
pull any big fingers have been torn to
shreds by the terrible and cruel wall
that did not yield to me oh and someone
told me that these ingots were useless
and I should never have turned my stuff
into that so you know yeah that's what
ever reclaimed water Oh No is that my
piss I have a bad feeling that reclaimed
water from my still suit is my piss
mixed in with my sweat for me
blasted rubles you blew my blue holes
all over the blasted place
how could you blow my need copper copper
any minute now to give me my delicious
copper would be nice that's not copper
don't ask me why I need copper I've got
a deliciously delectable plan one that
will shake the foundations of this very
world probably make you guys impressed
with what I'm doing but until I get that
copper I won't have what I need
warning incoming slap to your robotic
behind and not in a sexual way you know
sassy hey a sad fish a fish of sack give
me when he suck you is that enough might
be enough you don't know what I'm going
for
need some foodie woody and my Tommy
Tommy needs a foodie woody but I think
I've got all the materials that I need
what they think and when I think I know
what I'm doing is probably wrong because
when markiplier things things go badly
for marki moo-ha-ha here we go I got a
mobile vehicle Bay which means that I
should be able to build mobile vehicles
if I am not mistaken release fee vehicle
blade
I don't know I was trying to be dramatic
there but I didn't actually think of
anything to say when I was being
dramatic
so it turned out with a bunch of
gibberish give me your paper thank you
give me your paper I had you in my paper
Klaus also known as my hands you know
patented paper Klaus about those papers
hey PP oh no those are Peavy Birds not
fart sorry I miss my home I miss the
touch of another human oh I have her the
touch of fish and not like that come on
don't what was I doing I was doing oh
yeah I wanted to release the mobile
vehicle BAE why didn't I do that I got
distracted by paper fish and my own
insanity so I'm gonna deploy a mobile
vehicle BAE and with it I shall ride my
steed whoa she's a second in my face
how about Irish is a bunch of bull I
thought it was gonna be on the ground
okay well is this ridiculous this is now
what I was expecting
vehicles god plasteel ingot steel I
thought this is gonna be easier but what
the titties are you I'm gonna name you
Geoffrey Billy
Samwise and Marshall Marshall Samwise
Billy and Geoffrey Geoffrey Billy
Marshall Samwise Samwise Marshall Billy
Jeffrey Jeffrey Billy Samwise Marshall
Marshall Samwise Billy Jeffrey Jeffrey
Billy samurais
Marshall Samwise Billy Jeffrey don't get
it wrong guys this is Jeffrey
that's a moi no but that's March no that
this is Jeffrey that's Billy that's Sam
watts that's Markel I got it don't get
it wrong but anyway that does that
distracts me from what the hell is
frickin plasteel I don't know a shopkin
accomplished so Jeffrey come on you
gotta help me out here I don't know what
I'm doing
Sam why stop laughing at me Billy go
help out Marshall Marshall doesn't seem
to know what he's doing in life Oh
needed to enter base all right let me do
that at least God what a load of porker
hork what a load of Corpus crew what a
junkie piece of poopie pace what a
flabbergasted bag of sack oh well let me
just get my hatch and then I'll be able
to do what I need to do put it on there
why is it not there oh that's a little
dildo ask but you know what it's okay
BAM
no don't deconstruct it get in it oh man
oh why is it rocking in the ocean or is
that just me this is me okay so when I
turn I get drunk immediately okay now
we're getting somewhere
I got an underwater base I'm gonna be
doing good even though it's got no power
well I know how to make like you know
anything more high-tech than a door I
mean I'm gonna say no but frankly I want
to assume that maybe I could be okay
build this in moon pool why are you
bringing magic into this I don't know
what a moon
is it a neom time six nano glass
fragment analyzer I could build that I
guess fabric otter bench aquarium
perfect an aquarium I'm gonna have
little fishy friends I guess where's my
aquarium where's my query
I added my hands okay so I got to find a
way I got to find a way to get out ah
power of course solar panel on the
ground in the Sun I don't know what that
means
fine I'll do my best but no promises oh
god I should have built one with Windows
that would have been way smarter oh I
know I just got to find titanium and
then I should put a fabricator in there
but I don't know if I have enough for a
fabricator maybe again maybe not hello
what are you oh I got a Hoover fish
looks like mines Mia Jeffrey or Billy
Sam was Marshall Oh miss my babies
they're up on the ocean top also known
as the water why don't I have a blooper
thanks I'm fine I don't have a blooper
on my face that would be kind of helpful
you know I guess
uh wait I didn't think this through I
didn't get enough titanium dammit
alright you know what that's fine for
this episode so I'm doing okay I managed
to get inside the base and I built a
mobile vehicle bay not that that helped
me much at all but hey you know that is
what it is so I'm very tired I'm gonna
go to bed and in the next episode should
you guys want a next episode what I'll
do is I'll start a new game with all the
new updates I will get past to the point
where I am now I will build a bigger
base and I will gather more materials
and I'm gonna find a way to put the
materials into like a box so that I
don't have to lug them around with me so
that's what I'll do and hopefully it'll
work out for me I probably just need to
just deploy the storage cube must like
this submersible base building thing so
either way I'll figure it out in the
next one that I promise you I will not
be a scrub dad sigh usually I'm so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye